[Music]
yeah that's funny hey you guys i don't
know if you guys saw like at the very
beginning of this but i
actually because i don't know if you
guys use obs but i have like the little
starting soon video
and then i have that on and then i push
start streaming but then i push start
streaming before i put that video on so
at the very beginning of this at least
till i chop it off tomorrow there might
be like a couple seconds me going oh
[ __ ]
yeah i was sitting there taking a big
old [ __ ] belt out of this well at
least you weren't doing something like
embarrassing like picking your nose or
something like that
i don't pick my nose i have you pick my
nose
there's another shirt we're just i'm
coming up with so many shirts
you said crazy [ __ ] you know
that wasn't that crazy
i mean it's possible i'm sure it's
happening like somebody turned their
webcam on and then you're just like
since they're picking they're like oh
yeah i don't think i was doing that but
yeah i just mistaken like kind of
okay yeah so uh yeah it's the day before
christmas eve christmas eve
eve if you want to be that way about it
and this is our last christmas movie
review before
the big day we're actually not going to
be streaming tomorrow or friday which we
usually don't anyway it's not like we're
taking a
holiday like normal i went riding today
man i had to get the [ __ ] out of here
i took the buell lightning and [ __ ]
went for a ride yeah
yeah it felt a little bit better it was
nice out yeah
it was it was cold this morning it was
46.
it's nice for the [ __ ] apocalypse for
the end of the world
it'll be all right yeah okay i hope so
we were
it was funny because we were uh because
remember we said we've been watching
that uh
that leah remini science scientology
series and in season three like the
second to last episode
at least on netflix is they it was
actually really fascinating because they
went into
it was like an hour and a half long and
they went into jehovah's witnesses and
they talked to like all these jehovah's
witnesses because i guess like the
the structure of the churches is kind of
similar kind of yeah it's it's
ex-scientologists talking to ex
jehovah's witnesses
yeah it was like it was really really
interesting but yeah so that that's what
reminded me of it is jehovah's witnesses
are always talking about like the
apocalypse and how they're going to be
one of the 144 000 that get like
swooshed up to heaven
you guys know i'm all in that mythicism
religions and uh
one of the guys i subscribed to is an
ex-jehovah's witness and he was just
talking about that
institution it's it's it's structured
kind of like scientology but
yeah they're it's not as it's it's not
as money hungry
uh they really believe what they believe
i'm not sure if that's more or less
scary yeah and
the scientologist at the top just kind
of pretends to believe it yeah they're
just raking in the butt
and um and they're not as they're not as
violent the only thing they do this jobs
witness is they just kind of like bad
issue
and it's fellowship yeah it's just a
bunch of mind control
but see scientology does that too yeah
but it's not they're not putting you in
the hole
or putting you in the rpf or you know
which is not private
i don't think they are no although they
there do seem to be an inordinate amount
of child molesters at least like among
the people they were talking to in the
jehovah's witnesses i mean
yeah and they have a weird they have the
same like victim blaming thing that
scientologists have that if like
something bad happens to you then it's
your fault
well some of those people are in those
cults so they can do what they do
yeah well yeah exactly that's why
they're that's why that attracts like
so many of those types of people because
they won't rat on each other
yeah well they won't rat on each other
to the police
so you can they can get away with a lot
of [ __ ] yeah that's another thing that's
uh
similar and actually scientology it says
it right in their little uh l ron
hubbard instruction guides there is that
that is that is considered a suppressive
act if you
tell um a cop or an outside authority
what
if a scientologist does something
criminal you're not allowed to do that
or they kick you out yeah i don't think
scientology though is this
filled with [ __ ] child molesters
though as the jw or
jehovah's witnesses though well that
might just be statistical though because
there are more
jews witnesses than there are
scientologists yeah there's a bunch of
them
i wouldn't put it i would have put it
back there's eight million of them
yeah it's just like a weird it's a weird
thing well the thing is is that
you know the the priesthood in jehovah's
witness is not as micromanaged as the
priesthood in scientology
those guys are just never even alone
yeah you know
yeah they always have somebody like yeah
it's on the buddy system
i think it's i think it's harder in
jehovah's in in scientology
and i don't think it attracts the same
kind of person i just don't
yeah it doesn't have that veneer of
corporatism that scientology has
scientology is kind of like is kind of
like jehovah's witnesses mixed with
nexium
you know what i mean it's kind of like
that kind of well it's like mick
religion
religion yeah but it was as delicious as
that sounds like you guys have ever been
in a [ __ ] military it was based after
you know
navy the navy you know elven hubbard was
the name was a
naval officer yeah it's kind of like the
military
mixed with if you guys have ever been in
a [ __ ] corporation like a
that was big into sales like you know uh
then you would you see a lot in that
it's like
it's like a corporation that sells
windows or sells [ __ ] anything you
know what i mean or sells [ __ ]
magazines descriptions or vacuum
cleaners
it's that kind of a [ __ ] structure
where you you know
almost kind of like a pyramid scheme
yeah
kind of but uh everything has a
corporate veneer to it and there's books
for everything and you gotta [ __ ]
follow
why are we talking about this we gotta
talk about that you guys get me
sidetracked
because because you said something about
armageddon yeah
tila said my mom opened the door to
jova's witness let the woman in and i
as a toddler picked the scab off her leg
that's hilarious that's also a strangely
specific thing to remember jeez
that's really if you're like well i
thought she needed it picked off you
know it was just a witness is a doomsday
cult
it is yeah yeah they're just waiting for
armageddon they use the [ __ ] end of
the world to scare the people into line
being ready for the for the apocalypse
yeah but they're not getting ready for
the apocalypse
the way they say like a prepper is gonna
get rid of the apocalypse where he's
gonna have a bunch of guns and ammo and
training and equipment
no they're just gonna pray harder and
hope they make it you know
they're gonna be a bricklayers and [ __ ]
you know it's
they don't really have i don't think
they really have a good grasp of what an
apocalypse would be like
it's some crazy [ __ ] yeah you can pray
your way out of the apocalypse to
survive well they think they can
get your way on anything well and it's
weird too because and this all
this is the last thing i'm gonna say
about it but when i was in sixth grade
uh you know i there was a little kid in
my class his name was richard
and he was uh well i don't wanna say he
was a scientologist his parents were
not scientologists were jehovah's
witnesses um
and it always used to make me realize
because i didn't know what the [ __ ] that
was back then because i like i said i
wasn't rage religious
so every time that one of the parents
in the class like brought in little
cupcakes for like a holiday or someone's
birthday or something like that he had
to go sit in the teachers lounge like
they had to lock him in there because he
wasn't allowed to celebrate any holidays
and i was like what the [ __ ] kind of
[ __ ] religion is that
and i was like 11 years old yeah it's
not
it's not a very old cult i think it came
around about the 40s the 1940s i think
when it started and i might be wrong
about that but
most of the the writings i think come
from the 40s
and they just think that [ __ ] like
nuclear armageddon is going to come and
that's not the way that's not the way
an armageddon would look like or the end
of days or
the end of the united states it wouldn't
look like that it would look just like
the collapse of the soviet union it
would look just like that
just a wave of unemployment breakaway
republics poverty
[ __ ] a lot of them died it took a
decade for it to stabilize
and [ __ ] organized crime took over
and all the organized crime were all the
ex-military guys and guys xci8
xkgb dudes ran it that's what it would
look like
worse probably here worse but because
soviets are used to going without
electricity if you cut the power here
people [ __ ]
lose it can't use any of your devices
technology's bad no food delivery
yeah yeah you better learn how to plant
quick
better learn how to eat some of that
long pig i don't have a problem with
that yeah you'd be eating long pig
[Laughter]
you cook it right i'm sure it's
delicious there's less there's less than
a day of [ __ ] supplies in your local
dam
in your local uh grocery store when
there's no power
the computers don't work so nothing gets
delivered
and then it spirals out of control
there's a real good documentary on it
called
surviving i think it's called surviving
armageddon i think it's the name of it
it's about bio warfare no that that
talks about it
yeah i remember you talking about it
yeah it's a good one that was and it's
from like 20 years ago and it's
it what it's talking about is what you
see now
just what you've seen it's just
happening in slow motion
here right now you know i don't know how
real it was because
in that one the it was a pandemic where
the mortality rate was like 15 20
so it killed lots of people they were
stacked up at the end of the damn roads
diet you know what i mean it'd be like
one quarter of your block would die
you know when it's within a short period
of time
so yeah it's not the same as what you
have now i don't know how much i buy in
this [ __ ] it's just old people dying i'm
looking at the numbers and i was like
i'm not impressed
tila said prince was a jehovah's witness
he was that's
weird i didn't know that actually he
wasn't practicing you know he's just a
smoke
yeah you can't do anything you can't do
that's what i mean i just can't even eat
a [ __ ] birthday he must have left
what kind of religion is that
who would want to be in that he's
probably born in it
that's what i mean it's like that's i
feel bad for people that get born in it
that aren't scientology or anything like
that all right so let's talk about a
goddamn christmas movie how about that
yeah you might have seen it before
because
i think that this is the third
year that i have watched this movie
because i really really like this movie
a lot it's one of my favorite christmas
horror movies
this is called the christmas horror
story it's from 2015.
i think i first watched it um
christmas of 2017 and it was on netflix
back then
it is no longer on netflix at least in
the u.s because i just checked this
morning
it is however on shutter and i think it
might also be on amazon
prime i didn't see it on toby so like
check and uh and let me know
now this is a canadian horror anthology
set around christmas interestingly and i
did i've seen this [ __ ] thing three
times and i didn't even realize this
the three dudes that directed it because
like i said it's an anthology uh grant
harvey steve hoban and brett sullivan
also all worked on ginger snaps which we
reviewed just the other day
and the fictional town that this
anthology movie is set in is bailey
downs which is the same fictional town
that gingersnaps was set in and i didn't
even [ __ ] realize that until i was
watching this movie again this morning
so i was like well there you go and then
when i looked it up they were like oh
it's the guys
that did gingersnaps and i was like oh
well that explains it they're setting it
in the same fictional universe
so basically all i'm going to say okay
so i'll i'll give you the pitch of this
movie and then i have to spoil it a
little bit because it's like just
it's it's so it's so great
the chat is in this william shatner he
is in
the he's kind of like the wrap around
and almost kind of like the narrator
he plays a radio dj
called dangerous dan and so and it's
funny because
he kind of pops in you know periodically
like
giving you updates on some of the [ __ ]
and he's
drinking like eggnog with rum or whiskey
or something like that
so as as the movie goes on he's getting
progressively drunker
and like more and more depressed and
it's like really really
funny it's like he really really [ __ ]
sells it i mean it's
it's perfect so he's kind of like the
wrap around
and then um also i want to say too
that if you're a fan of i mean krampus
is in this
and i'm pretty sure that this was kind
of the first
big like major it wasn't super major
because i don't didn't even have
i don't even think it had a theatrical
release in the us maybe it was very very
limited i think it went straight to vod
which is a shame
so i feel like a lot of people maybe
just thought oh it's another stupid
you know christmas horror movie but this
one is actually really really good and
it's i was surprised like the first time
i saw it
so it has krampus in it it also has
krampus fighting santa claus and it also
has santa
killing zombie elves um so if that
doesn't sound badass enough
uh but there's other there's lots of
other really cool [ __ ] in this as well
so like i said you have dangerous dan
played by the chat
and he's talking about this town bailey
downs
it kind of the thing about this town
it's almost they don't really say this
explicitly but it's almost kind of like
every christmas like some bad [ __ ]
happens almost like this place is like
cursed or something
so they do kind of go into the year
prior
at the school um two
students were murdered and they still
haven't caught the person who did it and
it was like really creepy like all this
weird [ __ ] was written in blood on the
walls and [ __ ] like that
so the first story and it's
it's hard to say like first second third
fourth because what this does
you know how most anthologies they have
like the wrap around and they're like
here's the first story and then here's
the wrap-around bit again here's the
second story this one doesn't do that
this one basically has the four stories
running concurrently
so it kind of flips back and forth
between all four of them like it's
it's not confusing like i think some
people like thought it was like a little
confusing at first but i didn't find it
confusing
because it's not the stories aren't
necessarily
intertwined but some of the characters
are intertwined like you know what i
mean so it's like some of the characters
like turn up and some of the other ones
and it's like
you know what i mean so the first one
there's these high school students
and they're going to they're making like
a um
documentary for a school class and so
they want to break into the school which
is closed for
the christmas holiday obviously and they
want to film where the students from
last year were murdered like they want
to go down in the basement and
everything
now interestingly the girl who got them
the keys
to the school she is featured in
the second story or the third story
where she's going with her family
to visit their rich relative
i don't i don't remember if it's like
their aunt i think it's their aunt or
it's like their
grandparents or something like that and
um the dad
i guess he his business has been failing
and he doesn't have any money he don't
want to tell
his wife or kids about it so he's going
to aunt edda who has like all the money
and
is gonna ask her for it but it doesn't
go too well and that's where the whole
krampus thing starts
and then there's another story like
about the cop
who investigated the murders from the
prior year
and him and his wife and his little boy
are going out to this
uh you know going out in the woods they
want to find the perfect christmas tree
right so he
kind of goes onto this land that he's
maybe not supposed to go onto and
they find the perfect christmas tree but
then for a little while like they lose
their little boy and they can't find him
like he wandered off somewhere
and then they found and then they find
him and everything's okay but then they
take him home and that kid is acting
really weird
all of a sudden and uh so there's that
one
and then there's also a one where it's
set in the north pole
with santa claus and his elves
start acting i think the first one that
starts um acting up is named what the
[ __ ] is it
they all have names like jingles and
shiny and stuff like that sparkles and
stuff
and i guess all they eat is cookies so
like one of them
is basically like he didn't want to eat
cookies he is not hungry or and then he
dies and then he comes back as a zombie
and they're not only zombies but they
turn into these like real foul mouths i
mean
you know saying stuff to mrs claus like
you reindeer [ __ ]
snow horror or some [ __ ] like that and
that's
that segment like with santa killing all
the zombie elves
is probably the most fun and easily the
goriest i mean
santa who kind of looks like a big like
badass you know and he has like cool
hair he looks more like a
you know more like a traditional like
more pagani looking
santa claus and uh he's just in there
like
knocking off elves heads and
cutting their arms off and [ __ ] like
that so that one's super fun
and uh i think my favorite one though
the creepiest one
is the one with the the cop and his wife
and the kid in the woods
you know getting the tree because when
they bring that kid back home it turns
out that that kid
is a changeling and the way that they
shot it like the way it was all said it
was like super super creepy so i think
that was like kind of the
the best one creepy wise and the you
know the zombie elves and santa one
is the best one like entertainment wise
all of the stories are good i think the
one with the kids in the basement
like making the documentary is the
weakest one um and it's the least to do
with christmas
but it's still like it's still pretty
good like it's still a decent segment i
just think it's the
the least successful one out of all of
them and there's also
i won't spoil it but there's a twist
that has to do
with the santa and the elves and also
has to do
with william shatner's character
and the [ __ ] that he's talking about on
the radio because like i said he's doing
it's almost kind of like
um in the fog you know where like adrian
barbeau is kind of like
almost like narrating it because she's
like you know on the radio the whole
time it's kind of like that
but that ties in ends up tying in with
like the santa claus
[ __ ] too and like a really interesting
what are you doing i lost power
oh i thought maybe this thing must be on
a switch
ain't that something i don't know what
you're doing
he's like i don't know he just gets up
and like starts wandering around
i don't know what the [ __ ] going on
i don't know i think you know what i
think i've had trouble with that plug in
the past that's got to be because look
that's running
yeah but it's that that one plug i think
it's kind of squirrely yeah
that's [ __ ] weird yeah all right but
yeah so like i said i don't really want
to spoil the twist because
i really really liked the the twist at
the end of this one
because i like how it tied in you know
this
the one story like about santa and the
elves and then it also ties in with
uh the william shatner wrap around so i
thought that was kind of cool the way
that was done
so i mean seriously if you really really
like
christmas horror and you like horror
anthologies and i like both of those
things
then this is a really good one and i
feel like
i don't know i guess it's like kind of
underrated because like i said if you
just see it there's so many
christmas horror movies and especially
after this came out and after the movie
that was just called krampus or krampus
if you want to be
that way about it um after those came
out i feel like there were
like a [ __ ] ton of cheap jack straight
to vod
krampus movies um so maybe this one gets
lost in the shuffle because i think a
lot of the covers have like santa
fighting krampus on it
so people are like oh that's going to be
dumb or whatever but it's really it's
nothing like that it's it's actually
really good it's really fun
um you know all the segments are are
good like obviously a couple of them are
better than the other ones but that
usually happens with any anthology
um it's all of it's totally worth
watching and like i said it's
i i think that the main criticism i saw
like not a lot of
too many people criticizing it but the
main criticism i saw was like oh they
didn't like
um the stories running concurrently and
switching back and forth between them
instead of just letting one play out all
the way
but i actually liked that better because
then
you know each story it didn't get stale
you know what i mean because it was only
on screen for like a few minutes like
you saw
what happened in there and then they
went back like let's see what these
other people are doing
so i thought that was kind of better
like it kept it from getting
slow or kept it from getting bogged down
because you were just kind of
hitting the highlights and going back
and forth and if he got bored you know
it was going to the other story
and they do kind of they're not super
linked together but
like i said there is a little bit of
overlap with the characters it's all
happening in the same town like right
around the same time
so you know um but i think that's pretty
much
all i got to say about it like i said
it's on shutter
and i think it's on amazon prime so
basically go check it out because it's a
it's a really good flick and
like i said if you don't watch some
christmas horror movies because i do it
every year
and i think this is the third year that
i've watched it i felt i watched it in
2017 and then i watched it
maybe last year or the following year
and then i watched it again this year
um so yeah i think it's going to become
one that's going to go into the rotation
along with my christmas mst episodes
which i watch every year and uh you know
some various other ones too what else
you want to talk about i still can't get
power i don't know why i
look i switched them around it's fine
see maybe
your maybe your uh
charging cable is [ __ ] up no i don't
think that's what it is i think it's
this uh
i think it's the uh what do you call it
extension cord
yeah i don't know how old that extension
cord is so
that's all i gotta say about it that's
all i gotta say about it
all right well like i said we won't be
back again live until
saturday which will be the day after
christmas so i hope you guys have
enjoyed these christmas movie reviews
we've been
doing and i hope you guys all have a
really good
holiday everybody be have a good time be
safe try to like you know try to make
the best of it try to have a good time
i'm going to try to that's for sure but
yeah we'll see you guys again
on saturday and uh thanks for stopping
by merry christmas y'all
bye